voy a contarles un secreto
que ha sido gratamente enterrado por la historia.
En mi primera conferencia de prensa,
un periodista me preguntó, "Sra. Figueres,
¿Ud. cree que un acuerdo mundial será posible alguna vez?".
Y sin conectar con mi cerebro, oí mi rotundo,
"No en mi tiempo de vida".
Bueno, se pueden imaginar las caras de mi equipo de prensa
que estaba horrorizado por esta mujer loca de Costa Rica
que era su nueva jefa.
Y yo estaba horrorizada, también.
No estaba horrorizada de mí, porque estoy acostumbrada a mí misma.
En realidad estaba horrorizada
de las consecuencias de lo que acababa de decir,
de las consecuencias para el mundo
en el que todos nuestros hijos van a tener que vivir.
Fue un momento francamente horrible para mí,
y pensé, bueno, no, aguarda,
aguarda.
'Imposible' no es un hecho,
es una actitud.
No es más que una actitud.
Y decidí en ese mismo momento que iba a cambiar mi actitud
y que iba a ayudar al mundo a cambiar su actitud sobre el cambio climático.
Así que no sé...
¿Es solo esto? Gracias.
No sé...
qué harían
si les dijeran que su trabajo consiste en salvar el planeta.
Pónganlo en la descripción del trabajo.
Y tienen toda la responsabilidad,
pero no tienen absolutamente ninguna autoridad,
porque los gobiernos son soberanos en todas las decisiones que toman.
Bueno, realmente me gustaría saber
qué harían el primer lunes por la mañana,
pero aquí está lo que yo hice: entré en pánico.
(Risas)
Y luego entré pánico de nuevo,
porque me di cuenta de que no tenía idea de cómo resolver este problema.
Y entonces comprendí que no tenía idea de cómo resolver este problema,
pero sí sabía una cosa:
teníamos que cambiar el tono de la conversación.
Debido a que no hay manera de que se pueda lograr la victoria
sin optimismo.
Y aquí,
uso el optimismo como una palabra muy simple,
pero vamos a entenderla en su sentido más amplio.
Vamos a entenderla como coraje,
esperanza, confianza, solidaridad,
la creencia fundamental de que los humanos pueden unirse
y pueden ayudarse mutuamente para mejorar el destino de la humanidad.
Bueno, se pueden imaginar que pensé que, sin eso,
no había manera de salir de la parálisis de Copenhague.
Y durante seis años,
tenazmente, sin descanso inyecté optimismo en el sistema,
sin importar las preguntas de la prensa
--y he mejorado en eso--
y sin importar la evidencia en contra.
Y créanme, ha habido una gran cantidad de evidencia en contra.
Pero optimismo sin descanso en el sistema.
Y muy pronto,
empezamos a ver cambios que ocurrían en muchas áreas,
precipitados por miles de personas,
incluyendo muchos de los aquí presentes,
y se lo agradezco.
Y esta comunidad TED no se sorprenderá
si le digo que la primera área
en la que vimos cambios notables
fue...
en la tecnología.
Empezamos a ver que las tecnologías limpias,
en particular, las tecnologías de energías renovables,
comenzaron a bajar precios y aumentar capacidad,
hasta el punto de que hoy en día ya estamos construyendo
plantas de energía solar concentradas
que tienen capacidad para alimentar ciudades enteras,
por no hablar del hecho de lo que estamos haciendo en movilidad
y edificios inteligentes.
Y con este cambio de tecnologías,
hemos podido empezar a entender
que había un cambio en la ecuación económica,
porque hemos podido reconocer
que sí, hay enormes costos por el cambio climático,
y sí, hay riesgos compuestos.
Pero también hay ventajas económicas
y beneficios intrínsecos,
debidos a la difusión de las tecnologías limpias
que nos van a traer un aire más limpio,
mejor salud,
un mejor transporte, ciudades más habitables,
más seguridad energética,
más acceso a la energía para el mundo en desarrollo.
En suma, un mundo mejor que el que tenemos ahora.
Y con esa comprensión,
de la que debieron haber sido testigos, de hecho, parte de Uds. lo fueron,
la propagación del ingenio y la emoción
que se dio, primero a través de gobiernos no nacionales,
el sector privado, los capitanes de la industria, las compañías de seguros,
inversionistas, líderes de ciudades, comunidades religiosas,
porque todos comenzaron a entender que, en realidad, esto podía ser de su interés.
En realidad, esto puede mejorar su cuenta de resultados.
Y no fueron solo los sospechosos de siempre.
Les digo que tuve al presidente de una gran, gran empresa de petróleo y gas
que vino a mí a principios del año pasado
y dijo,
en privado, por supuesto,
que no sabía cómo iba a cambiar su compañía,
pero que iba a cambiarla,
porque estaba interesado en la viabilidad a largo plazo.
Pues bien, ahora tenemos un cambio en la ecuación económica,
y con eso, con el apoyo más amplio de todo el mundo,
no pasó mucho tiempo antes de que viéramos que los gobiernos nacionales
despertaban al hecho de que se trataba de su interés nacional.
Y cuando les pedimos a los países que comenzaran a identificar
cómo podrían contribuir a los esfuerzos mundiales
pero con base en su interés nacional,
189 países de los 195,
189 países enviaron sus planes sobre el cambio climático,
en función de su interés nacional,
concurrente con sus prioridades,
compatible con sus planes nacionales de desarrollo sostenible.
Bien,
una vez se protegen los intereses fundamentales de las naciones,
uno puede entender que las naciones estaban listas
para comenzar a converger hacia un camino común,
en una dirección común de viaje
que nos va a llevar probablemente varias décadas,
pero durante esas décadas nos va a llevar
a la nueva economía,
a descarbonizar la economía, una economía muy resiliente.
Y las contribuciones nacionales que están actualmente sobre la mesa
en nombre de los gobiernos nacionales
no son suficientes para llevarnos a un clima estabilizado,
pero son solo el primer paso,
y van a mejorar con el tiempo.
Y la medición, notificación y verificación de todos esos esfuerzos
es legalmente vinculante.
Y los puntos de control que vamos a tener cada cinco años
para evaluar el progreso colectivo hacia nuestra meta son legalmente vinculantes,
y el mismo camino hacia descarbonizar y hacia una economía más resiliente
es legalmente vinculante.
Y aquí está la parte más importante:
¿Qué teníamos antes?
Un pequeño puñado de países
que había llevado a cabo unos muy reducidos
compromisos de reducción de emisiones, a corto plazo,
que eran totalmente insuficientes
y además, en gran medida percibidos como una carga.
¿Ahora qué tenemos?
Ahora tenemos a todos los países del mundo contribuyendo con diferente intensidad
desde diferentes enfoques en diferentes sectores,
pero todos ellos contribuyendo a un objetivo común
y a lo largo de un camino
con integridad medioambiental.
Pues bien, una vez uno tiene todo esto en su lugar
y ha cambiado ese entendimiento,
a continuación, se ve que los gobiernos fueron capaces de ir a París
y adoptar el acuerdo de París.
(Aplausos)
Así que,
cuando miro hacia atrás
durante los últimos seis años,
lo primero que recuerdo
es el día en que se adoptó el acuerdo de París.
No puedo describirles la euforia en el ambiente.
5000 personas saltando de sus asientos,
llorando, aplaudiendo, gritando, chillando,
divididos entre la euforia y la aún incredulidad ante lo que acababan de ver,
porque muchas personas
habían trabajado durante años en esta dirección, y fue finalmente su realidad.
Y no fue solo aquellos que habían participado directamente.
Unas semanas atrás, estaba con un colega
que estaba tratando de decidir
sobre una perla de Tahití que quería darle a su maravillosa esposa Natasha.
Una vez que finalmente decidió la que iba a comprar,
el joyero le dijo:
"Sabe, es muy afortunado de comprar esto ahora,
porque estas perlas podrían extinguirse muy pronto a causa del cambio climático".
"Pero", dijo el joyero, "¿ha oído,
que los gobiernos acaban de llegar a una decisión,
y Tahití podría tener una oportunidad?".
Bueno, fue una confirmación fantástica
de que quizás, quizás aquí hay esperanza,
aquí hay una oportunidad posible.
Soy la primera en reconocer que tenemos mucho trabajo por hacer.
Hace solo unos minutos empezamos nuestro trabajo sobre cambio climático.
Y de hecho, hay que asegurarse de que redoblemos nuestros esfuerzos
durante los próximos cinco años, que son los urgentes cinco años.
Pero sí creo
que hemos llegado en los últimos seis años
de lo imposible
a lo ya imparable.
¿Y cómo hacemos esto? Mediante la inyección del optimismo transformacional
que nos permitió ir de la confrontación a la colaboración,
que nos permitió entender que los intereses nacionales y locales
no están necesariamente en contradicción con las necesidades globales,
y que, si entendemos esto, podemos unirlos
y podemos combinarlos armónicamente.
Y cuando miro adelante a otros temas globales
que requerirán nuestra atención este siglo,
la seguridad alimentaria, la del agua, en el hogar, la migración forzada,
veo que ciertamente no sabemos aún
cómo vamos a resolver estos problemas.
Pero podemos tomar una página de lo que hemos hecho sobre el cambio climático
y podemos entender
que tenemos que reinterpretar la mentalidad de suma cero.
Debido a que fuimos entrenados para creer que siempre hay ganadores y perdedores,
y que su pérdida es mi ganancia.
Bueno, ahora que estamos en un mundo
en el que hemos alcanzado los límites del planeta
y que no estamos solo interconectados,
sino cada vez somos más interdependientes unos de otros,
tu pérdida ya no es más mi ganancia.
O bien somos todos perdedores
o podemos ser todos ganadores.
Pero vamos a tener que decidir
entre cero y suma.
Vamos a tener que decidir entre el beneficio cero para todos
o vivir la vida como la suma de todos nosotros.
Ya lo hemos hecho una vez. Podemos hacerlo de nuevo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)